bon les gars pour ce matin françois et
gaël vous ferez une patrouille pédestre
en priorisant les contacts commerçants
c'est l'une des dernières consignes
données à ces hommes alain salomé
responsable de la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux va prendre sa
retraite dans quelques jours en restant
en liaison radio
pour l'instant il part en patrouille
avec rémy dans une zone pavillonnaire de
la commune dans les zones pavillonnaires
notre présence est quand même
indispensable dans la journée car les
gens sont au travail laisse la maison
vide jusque ce soir une dissuasion qui
peut parfois mener à l'intervention les
policiers municipaux vie si noah ont dû
mener une opération sur le cambriolage
d'une maison par plusieurs individus
notre arrivée sur façon
vous intervenez en fait vendu liées avec
du temps de 10 av
des fractures et
portes portes fenêtres en pvc
et il a bien retourné
la maison intérieur arrivé à la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux en
tant que stagiaire en 2001 alain salomé
a gravi des échelons jusqu'à devenir
responsable en 2005 après avoir été
gendarme pendant près de 20 ans en 99
j'avais passé le concours de la police
municipale parce qu'elle ait pas de
passerelle à l'époque vous pouvez pas
passer de la gendarmerie à la police
municipale donc j'ai passé le congo
l'échelle de la commune est très
intéressante pour tout ce qui est
contacts et renseignements auprès de la
population contact auprès des citoyens
plusieurs dossiers municipaux comme
l'obtention des pistolets à impulsion
électrique ou encore l'installation de
la vidéo protection
avec un marché conclu avant son départ
pour la remise à niveau des caméras sur
trois ans arrivé à 57 caméras dont dont
pas mal de caméras en lecture de plaques
qui nous permet de visualiser les
véhicules qui rentre et qui sortent des
quartiers donc ça très intéressant pour
nous aussi sur les camps volage avec
cinq agents la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux est une véritable
famille pour alain salomé je pense
qu'ils sont quand même satisfait de 2,2
de mon commandement mais j'avais pomme
même passé un commandement c'est naturel
c'est une personne très humaine qui
qui fait preuve de très grande
compétence pour attribuer les missions
et aussi comment exécuter les missions
parce que des fois c'est vrai qu'il faut
prendre des dispositions sur certaines
interventions il a toujours su nous nous
diriger dans le bon sens au bout de 17
ans qu'est ce qu'on va on est content
j'imagine d'être à la retraite et en
même temps dit on est content mais je
lâche une équipe quoi après 17 ans de
service le néo-retraité va pouvoir en
profiter notamment chez lui à
rambouillet et dans un pays qu'il
apprécie particulièrement l'espagne